in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for September 29th, on which we commemorate,
our righteous Father, Kediakos, anchorite of Palestine.
On the 29th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father, Kediakos, the anchorite.
St. Kediakos was born in Corinth in the year 448, during the reign of the Emperor Thodosius II.
He was the son of a priest of the Church of Corinth called John and of Aloxia, his devout wife.
When he was 18, he was ordained reader by Peter, the bishop of the city. He was his father's uncle.
With an ardent longing for God in his heart, he left Corinth with the knowledge of his family and headed for Jerusalem.
When he arrived in the Holy City, he heard tell of the ascetic feats of St. Athemios.
He asked to become one of his disciples.
St. Athemios clothed him in the holy angelic habit, but was unwilling for him to stay in his lava,
lest his youth become a stumbling block to others.
And he sent him to St. Yerasimus, who dwelt near the Jordan.
There he did well in his obedience as cook, and he made such progress in holy ascetic virtues and in prayer,
that St. Yerasimus allowed him to spend the time from the end of theophany to Palm Sunday in the desert of Ruba with him each year.
They were in the desert when the departure to heaven of the soul of St. Athemios was revealed to Yerasimus,
and he and Kiryakos set out to bury his body.
St. Yerasimus himself fell asleep in the peace of the Lord when Kiryakos, who was then 27, had been with him for nine years.
They were now prepared to accept him in the lava of St. Athemios and Kiryakos dwelt there in solitude for a time,
although he favored its becoming a sonobium.
He did not stay long, for love had grown cold among the monks, who were involved in continual disputes with the monastery of St. Thoctistus, situated just below them.
Fleeing scandal and trouble, Kiryakos took up his abode in the lava of St. Kariton at Sukha.
He stayed there for many years, serving the community in various obedience.
When he was forty, he was ordained priest and appointed sacristan throughout the years.
He never once gave way to anger, nor eight before sunset.
At the age of seventy, he went away with one disciple into the wilderness of Natuva, where he endured torments of all kinds for the love of Christ,
and lived on nothing but wild onions, that miraculously lost their bitterness at his prayer.
Monks and the faithful from all parts sought him out in his retreat, some to be freed from evil spirits, others to hear a word of salvation.
And so, notwithstanding his ninety years, Kiryakos had to leave for a more remote desert called Susakim, where he lived alone with a team lion that watched over his little garden.
A deadly epidemic that ravaged the region at the time brought the fathers of the lava of St. Kariton to St. Kiryakos, begging him to come back to them,
so as to protect them by his prayers.
During his second stay at Sukha, he fought with a sharp sword of the word of his spiritual knowledge against the originous terracy that had led many Palestinian monks astray.
When he was ninety-nine years old and weary of the troubles that human society brought upon him, he went back to the desert of Susakim,
where he lived for eight years more in extreme askees among the angels and saints.
He fell asleep in peace full of grace and godliness at 107 years of age.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.